MOTIVATES ME.
CHRIS: WE ARE BACK, LAKERS MEDIA
DAY.
ALLIE, BIG GAME JAMES, THERE HE
IS.
HE LOOKS GOOD IN THAT UNIFORM.
DOESN'T HE?
JAMES: I LIKE THAT PURPLE AND
GOLD.
>> CHRIS: BEING CHRIS: A LAKER
FAN MY WHOLE LIFE, I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD SEE RUSS IN A
LAKER UNIFORM.
PLAYERS WITH 20,000 POINTS, 8000
ASSISTS, HOW ABOUT THESE NAMES?
LEBRON, OSCAR, GARY PAYTON,
RUSS.
HE'S THE ALL-TIME LEADER IN NBA
HISTORY.
HE'S A NINE TIME ALL-STAR.
HE LED THE LEAGUE IN ASSISTS
LAST YEAR.
I'M TALKING ABOUT RUSSELL
WESTBROOK IN A LAKER UNIFORM,
HOW ARE WE DOING?
RUSSELL: I'M GREAT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR HAVING ME.
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
CHRIS: YOU ARE NOT NEW TO MEDIA
DAY AND A NEW CITY BUT THIS CITY
IS L.A.
THE TEAM YOU GREW UP ROOTING
FOR.
YOU WENT TO UCLA, THIS IS YOUR
HOME.
I REMEMBER WHEN YOU FIRST GOT
TRADED AND YOU SAID IT HAD NOT
SUNK IN YET.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
FEELINGS TODAY GOING INTO THIS
MOMENT?
RUSSELL: IT IS STILL SURREAL.
IT PROBABLY WON'T HIT ME UNTIL
OPENING NIGHT.
I'M JUST SOAKING IT ALL IN.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE I LOOKED
DOWN AT MY JERSEY LIKE IT IS A
LAKERS JERSEY.
I AM SUPER EXCITED.
I CANNOT WAIT UNTIL WE GET THIS
THING ROLLING.
JAMES: WELCOME BACK HOME.
IT IS NICE TO HAVE YOU.
I WAS DOWN VAN NUYS THE OTHER
DAY.
I START RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
I WAS JUST THINKING, WELCOME
HOME.
SO MANY QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE GETTING ASKED HOW WILL
YOU FLOW WITH A.D. AND LEBRON.
IT IS SOMETHING I ALWAYS WANTED
TO ASK YOU, JUST WATCHING YOUR
CAREER.
HOW DO YOU DEFINE IN YOUR WORDS,
KILLER INSTINCT?
RUSSELL: CONSISTENCY.
I BELIEVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
KILLER INSTINCT YOU HAVE TO DO
IT CONSISTENTLY.
I LEARNED SOMETHING A LONG TIME
AGO.
BEING CONSISTENT IS THE HARDEST
THING TO DO IN THIS LEAGUE.
THEY DO IT IN THIS LEAGUE EVERY
NIGHT, OVER AND OVER.
IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT.
LEAVE IT ALL ON THE FLOOR.
ALLIE: THERE WAS A GREAT
QUESTION.
WITH THAT SAID, IN ORDER FOR THE
LAKERS TO DO WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO, THAT IS GET BACK TO THE TOP,
YOU, LEBRON JAMES, ANTHONY DAVIS
STARTING IS THE LEADERS HAVE TO
BE THE BEST VERSIONS OF
YOURSELF.
WHEN YOU THINK OF THAT, ALL
WHILE WALKING THAT FINE LINE OF
SACRIFICE, HOW DO YOU DO IT?
RUSSELL: YOU DO WHAT IT TAKES
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF THE TEAM.
IF YOU WANT TO WIN, NOTHING WILL
GET IN THE WAY OF THE SACRIFICES
YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS IS
WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS LOCKER
ROOM.
MY JOB IS TO MAKE SURE I COULD
UPLIFT AND MAKE MY TEAMMATES
BETTER.
MAKE LEBRON AND A.D. BETTER.
MAKING TEAMMATES AROUND US THAT
ARE SO WE ULTIMATELY COULD REACH
OUR GOAL, TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
CHRIS: ON OUR SHOWS THE LAST FEW
WEEKS WE TALKED ABOUT YOU
JOINING LEBRON AND A.D., THE
SACRIFICE IT TAKES.
YOU PLAYED WITH JAMES HARDEN,
K.D., NOBODY KNOWS MORE THAN YOU
HAVE TO FIT WITH OTHER
SUPERSTARS.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE KEYS TO
SUCCESS TO HAVE THAT VISION YOU
THREE HAVE TO TRANSLATE TO
WINNING?
RUSSELL: I LIKE TO LEARN MY
TEAMMATES, UNDERSTAND THEM NOT
JUST ON THE FLOOR BUT OFF THE
FLOOR.
YOU LEARN HOW THEY OPERATE.
IT HELPS COMMUNICATION.
IT HELPS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT GUYS
LIKE, WHAT THEY DON'T LIKE.
I AM ALL INTO MAKING MY
TEAMMATES BETTER.
MAKE THE GAME EASIER FOR THEM.
HONESTLY, I JUST CARE ABOUT
WINNING.
TO BE ABLE TO WIN, A.D. AND
LEBRON HAVE TO BE THE BEST THEY
HAVE BEEN.
I HAVE TO DO THE THINGS I CAN TO
MAKE THEM BETTER.
ALLIE: YOU LIKE TO HAVE FUN.
THIS IS A TWO-PART QUESTION.
YOU WERE AT ANTHONY DAVIS'S
WEDDING.
HOW WAS THE WEDDING?
RUSSELL: THE WEDDING WAS GOOD,
HAD A LOT OF TIME DANCING.
ALLIE: WITH THAT SAID, WE SAW
YOU IN PHOTOS WITH JARED DUDLEY.
SOMEONE WHO IS BELOVED HERE.
IT HAS BEEN SAID YOU PICK HIS
BRAIN.
YOU JUST WANTED TO NOAH LITTLE
BIT MORE.
WHAT DID YOU TAKE FROM THAT
CONVERSATION?
RUSSELL: DUDLEY IS A GOOD FRIEND
OF MINE.
HE HAS BEEN AROUND HERE.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT TAKES TO WIN.
HE UNDERSTANDS THE ORGANIZATION.
I JUST WANTED TO LEARN A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE ORGANIZATION
AND HOW THINGS ARE RAN.
WHAT THE CC WITH ME FITTING IN?
HE HAS BEEN AROUND A.D., BEEN
AROUND BROWN.
YOU COULD ALWAYS LEARN MORE EACH
AND EVERY DAY.
I WANTED TO TALK TO HIM AND
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE MORE ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
EVEN THOUGH HE IS IN DALLAS, HE
STILL COMMUNICATED.
HE IS A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
CHRIS: I KNOW A DAY DOESN'T GO
BY THAT YOU DON'T THING ABOUT
YOUR GOOD FRIEND KOBE BRYANT.
HE LOVED YOUR GAME AND FIRE.
HOW MUCH WOULD HE HAVE LOVED
SEEING YOU IN THAT UNIFORM?
RUSSELL: THAT IS SOMETHING I
THINK ABOUT DAILY, COMING TO THE
GYM.
YOU COME IN HERE AND YOU SEE A
AND 24.
I KNOW HE IS LOOKING DOWN AND
MAKING SURE THAT I NEED TO DO
WHAT I NEED TO DO.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT I
COULD THINK ABOUT.
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT I COULD
HAVE BEING A LAKER.
CREATING A LEGACY.
NOT JUST FOR MYSELF BUT FOR MY
KIDS, THE COMMUNITY OF LOS
ANGELES, I WILL MAKE SURE I DO
MY PART IN PLAYING FOR HIM.
CHRIS: I KNOW I SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE AT THE NETWORK.
WE ARE SO EXCITED TO HAVE YOU IN
THE PURPLE AND GOLD.
WE ARE PROUD OF YOU REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU, SO MUCH.
JAMES: GREAT W